you and i were meant to be out here
in the darkness
that's who we are born to be
hey guys pete here i just watched the
expanse panel at new york city comic con
2021 and thought i'd do a quick video to
let you know what they said about the
final season they also dropped a new
trailer it was a very final season sort
of don't give much away kind of teaser
there was no mention if there would be
something more substantial to follow but
either way i'll come back and do a full
breakdown of that after i've had some
time to look at it more closely so it is
confirmed that season six will be six
episodes they're gonna be airing them
weekly it's gonna start on december 10th
the first episode will come out then and
then each one will follow weekly until
they get to the finale just one episode
a week no mini binge at the beginning so
we have exactly six more weeks of the
expanse they did say that the final
episode will be 65 minutes long and they
said that was something that they always
wanted to do was end big the panel was
like the other ones you've seen
dominique tipper did the hosting and
then there were several cast members and
then the writers and the show runner so
we had steven strait who plays holden
wes chatham who plays amos shirae who
plays avasarala nadine nicole who plays
clarissa and caraji who plays drummer
and then we had narain shankar the
showrunner ty frank and daniel abraham
the two authors of the novels who
produce and write for the show i thought
it was interesting when they were
talking about going with six episodes no
one said that this was the idea that
they had in mind or this was something
that they wanted to do because they
thought the story called for it they put
an emphasis on how it was much shorter
than what they're used to and narain
even said that it was difficult but it
gives it intensity and it really sets up
for an ending that's cathartic tai said
they had to stand on the gas pedal all
the way but then daniel jumped in to say
that he didn't think they lost anything
and he pointed out some of the things
that we've been talking about how they
pulled things forward to season five and
overall they sounded confident that they
pulled it off as far as what the cast
had to say they all felt like it was
surreal that they were coming to the end
of their journey bobby couldn't be there
because she was filming something else
they mentioned losing alex and how that
changes things but didn't give any more
details about how the crew would be
filled out instead each of them kind of
focused on where their character's at in
the beginning it sounds like things are
pretty rough steven strait said that
morale is really low the war is dragging
on and there's a sense that they haven't
gotten anywhere it's wearing on holden
and the rest of the crew naomi's angry
about the part that she played in alex's
death that's hanging over all of them no
one seems to be happy that clarissa is
there except for amos and they're flying
around fighting with and killing belters
and as you can imagine that's hard for
naomi west chatham brought up the fact
that amos used to use these other people
as his moral compass and now he finds
clarissa doing the same thing with him
he's starting to make his own choices
and not necessarily questioning holden
but wanting to understand things on a
deeper level it sounds like there's a
real sense of why do we have to be in
the middle of all this
nadine said that clarissa is just trying
to keep her head down and trying to
prove her worth to these people who she
tried to kill they did hint that we'll
see a lot of the aftermath of the rocks
falling on earth and they phrased it in
the way that earth gets literally
obliterated the ecosystem's breaking
down there's so many deaths and there's
so many other problems related to that
and it's all on alba serala's shoulders
she's lost her husband and there seems
to be a constant stress that it's still
not over and they don't know what to
expect charade did say that bobby and
avasarala get to reunite she said they
have a real connection she sees herself
and bobby and she can see the qualities
in her that other people can't and then
the cast interviews ended with drummer
and they talked about how she's just
basically floating around with what's
left of her family she's backed into a
corner with nowhere to go and
everything's pretty hopeless for her at
the beginning she doesn't really like
earth she wants independence for the
belt but she doesn't like the free navy
either and she can't get on board with
marco
the idea of the protomolecule was
brought up and one of the more exciting
things that they confirmed was that they
will be doing an adaptation of strange
dogs in the season they said that would
include showing more of laconia and an
idea of what the future will look like
later on in the story of course they
didn't make any announcements of future
adaptations of book
and nine so at least at this point it's
just what the future will look like but
we may never actually see that i think
they tried to address the idea of not
being able to wrap that whole story up
they reinforced the idea that that's
what the later books are about they said
that thing is still there though how
humans keep encountering the
proto-molecule and keep trying to make
it into what they want and daniel said
tai describes it as the rock against
which people break themselves so its
presence will be felt but there will be
lingering mysteries at the end so not a
whole lot of surprises there if you're
familiar with the sixth book then you
can probably map out what's going to
happen it is exciting and you see a bit
of it in the trailer that there's some
laconia and some strange dogs it sounds
like it's going to be intense it sounds
like it's going to be really streamlined
i hope that works well we've seen them
do that before six episodes is kind of a
disappointment but i have faith that
they'll give us something good i made a
whole video about how that might work so
you can check that out and the last
thing they mentioned is that there's
gonna be short five to six minute
segments that they're going to be
putting out in between episodes so
that'll be interesting to see what they
do with that like additional materials
in between and those were my big
takeaways and i think that's a good
place to leave things like i said i'll
be back with the trailer breakdown soon
and in the meantime i'm curious to hear
what you think about the news in the
comments let me know what you're
thinking we've got just about two months
until the first episode drops so what
are you hoping to see and they did
change the release date for book nine
leviathan falls is going to be coming
out on november 30th rather than
november 16th so we're going to get the
end of the books and then we're going to
get the end of the tv series in pretty
close succession please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon